in the last video we talked about how we
could create a voltaic cell or galvanic
cell or essentially a battery by
separating the oxidation and the
reduction reactions and connecting them
with the wire which forces the electrons
that zinc is losing to go through the
wire to go to copper to go to the copper
ion so that they can get them so that
they the copper ions can be reduced now
that might have raised some questions if
this is a battery well what is the
positive terminal what is the negative
terminal if this is a battery what is
the voltage of this battery
well i'll encourage you first of all
when you think about the terminal what's
the positive and what's the negative
terminal i encourage you to pause this
video and think about that on your own
where is the current coming from and
where is it going
well the negative terminal of a battery
is where the electrons are coming from
so the electrons are coming from the
zinc bar right over here so this is the
negative electrode of the battery that
right over there or the negative
electrode is often called the anode that
is the anode of this battery
and on the other side the copper bar
this is where the electrons are going to
this is the positive that's the positive
electrode or sometimes called or what
tends to be called the cathode
now the next question is what is the
voltage across is that voltage is going
to depend on what's the concentration of
zinc ions you have the concentration of
copper ions you have it'll depend on the
pressure it'll depend on the temperature
but all of that has been standardized
and you can actually look up standard
electrode potentials and i encourage you
you could do a web search for standard
electrode potentials and you'll see a
bunch of voltages for different ions and
which is essentially a measure of
relative to hydrogen and this is all
relative to hydrogen how much does this
ion want to grab its electrons and so if
you were to look that up you would get
it for this reaction right over here for
the copper for the copper ion with an
oxidation state a two
with an oxidation number of positive two
to grab these two electrons and turn it
into co solid copper
relative to
relative to a the what they call the
standard hydrogen electrode
that has a 0.34
voltage which means that it's it's it's
it's it's more likely to happen than the
case with a standard with a standard
hydrogen electrode and don't worry too
much about that we're really just going
to compare the voltages and seeing and
seeing well what is the total
electromotive force or the total voltage
with which this this redoc reaction is
going to happen and or the total
electromotive force with which we're
going to push these electrons across the
wire
if you were to look up the zinc reaction
in a table of standard electrode
potentials you might see you might see
negative 0.76
now you have to be careful though
because they're going to give you
they're usually this if they're giving
you this number they're giving you the
opposite reaction here they're giving
the reaction from going from zinc ions
grabbing some electrons and becoming and
becoming solid zinc we want the other
reaction this is the reaction that we
need to occur for our galvanic cell so
this reaction right over here is going
to be the negative of that so it's going
to be positive 0
or positive 0.76
volts so one way to think about it is
this wants to happen with an
electromotive force or kind of the
energy per coulomb relatively of 0.76
volts this wants to happen with the
electromotive force here is
0.34 volts so combined this entire
reaction is going to happen with an
electro electromotive force or you could
say that the potential per coulomb
difference between this side and that
side is going to be the sum of these two
things and so that's going to be
if we if we have the standard
concentration which would be one one
molar which is one mole per liter of the
ions in the in their aqueous solution if
we're at standard temperature standard
pressure then we would have essentially
constructed a
1.1
volt battery and i've just added these
two things together
and of course there's other ways you
could do it you could literally i mean
you could literally just take a volt
meter and measure what is the volt
without the current there without the
current flowing you could literally just
measure what is the voltage difference
between these two terminals just as you
would do in a traditional battery